لا شك الحقيقه حائل تقع لثقب المعروفه
لجميع في شمال المملكه في وسط شمال
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
تبين لهيئه التراث نهايه الاثار لهيه
الاثار وجود الحقيقه نقشين
يعودان الى الملك
البابلي وهو اخر ملوك بابل نابوليت وهذا
يعتبر بحد ذات الحقيقه اكتشاف علمي متميز
الان تجري الحقيقه
الابحاث والدراسات في الهيئه من اجل كشف
همم غموض هذا الناس وما هو وما يتضمن هذا
النص من من معلومات عن هذا الملك الذي قدم
الى شمال شبه جزيره العربيه
وتمكن من السيطره على عدد من مدنها
المعروفه انا ذاك اللي هي تيماء وديدان
وخيبر وفدك اللي هي اليوم تسمى الحائط
وكذلك اخر هذه المدن مدينه الرسول عليه
الصلاه والسلام
نعم نعم
قبل الاسلام بكم تقريبا
اكثر من الف سنه الف سنه وشويه الف سنه
و100 تقريبا وفي القرن الخامس
قبل الميلاد هذا نابونيت كان اخر ملوك
مملكه بابل هي الفتره الثانيه الباب
الثاني يسمونه او الكلدانيه
هو ابن احد يعني العوائل العوائل المعروفه
والنبيله في مدينه بابل همم قلده الكهنه
مجمع الكهنه في ذلك في تلك الفتره زمام
الامور في بابل وفي التصور طبعا ان قدومه
لهذه المنطقه كان بهدف همم تاسيس وانشاء
مملكه جديده له لانه تبين له لفريقه
الحاكم انا ذاك في بابل ان الظروف
انا ذاك طبعا في ذلك الوقت لم تكن مواطنيه
استمرار الامبراطوريه البابليه العظيمه
التي كان احد ملوكها اعظم ملوك تلك الفتره
ان ابوخذ نصر التي تعود اليه الحدائق
المعلقه احدى عجائب الدنيا السبع همم
واكبر واضخم سور بني في بابل في العالم
انا ذاك كان بني حول مملكه بابل او مدينه
بابل تحديدا العاصمه في عهد هذا الملك
مختصر